Haití necesita ayuda internacional el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez visitó Puerto Príncipe para
recordar que Haití necesita al mundo
hago un llamamiento a la comunidad
internacional para que acuden a ayuda de
las poblaciones necesitadas es una
cuestión de solidaridad pero también de
Justicia social
cinco punto dos millones de haitianos
casi la mitad de la población sufren una
grave inseguridad alimentaria y el
llamamiento de la ONU para recaudar 720
millones de dólares en ayuda para el
país tiene menos de una cuarta parte
financiada Mientras tanto el 80% de la
población en la capital está bajo el
control o influencia de las pandillas
tiroteos secuestros y la violencia
sexual son algunas de sus armas la ONU
pide a sus miembros que dediquen
recursos para proporcionar acciones
rápidas
instó a los estados que tienen capacidad
para proporcionar una fuerza de
seguridad sólida para que deje de dudar
y esté dispuesto a acatar una decisión
del Consejo de Seguridad
además de la crisis política y la
violencia provocada por las pandillas
los haitianos siguen sufriendo los
estragos de continuas catástrofes
climáticas a principios de junio más de
40 personas murieron por las
inundaciones provocadas por intensas
lluvias en la isla una situación que
continúa intensificando la crisis
humanitaria en el país